what if I told you that there was one
thing that you could do in your 1l year
that is scientifically proven to improve
your grade by at least a third of a
grade in all of your law school classes
well that thing really exists and we're
gonna talk about what it is and how you
can use it to your advantage to improve
your grades in law school law professors
love to write academic papers but unlike
other fields few actually test their
theories in the real world but
professors Dan Schwartz and Dean far
ganas at the university Minnesota law
school ran a study that suggests that
law students who get individualized
feedback from their professors in one
subject are more likely to do better in
all of their classes think about that if
you can get feedback on how to do better
in a law school final exam not only will
you do better in that class but you will
do better in all of your law school
classes what the professor's did is they
ran an experiment on 1l students in
their first year classes what they found
is absolutely amazing their experiment
consisted of a certain section of
students who were given individualized
feedback on practice tests versus a
control group who received no
instruction whatsoever controlling for
all other factors like LSAT scores
undergrad GPA etc the experimental group
saw their grades increase by one third
of a grade in all of their classes that
is turning a b-plus into an a-minus or
an A into an A+ and it was in every
single one of their classes on average
you can find the study at the Journal of
legal education is called the impact of
individualized feedback on law school
performance this study is amazing but
it's not terribly surprising when you
think about it traditionally law school
is an entire semester of not knowing
what the hell you're doing followed by a
test that is worth a hundred percent of
your grade and the worst part is that
professors almost always use issue
spotting exams so while the subject
matter
may change the tactics stay the same and
the the test doesn't look like what you
talked about in class but look at the
bright side most students won't get any
feedback most don't know that there are
repeatable strategies to acing law
school exams and most students put off
taking practice exams until the very
last minute if they take any practice
tests at all but the thing about
practice tests is that they give you the
feedback that you need even if it's not
your professor him or herself that's
giving you the feedback you can have
other students give you the feedback you
can self evaluate and get the feedback
from yourself you can learn the
strategies of how to take law school
essay exams and what this study shows is
that once you take the leap and you
start taking practice exams you will do
better not only in the class that you're
taking practice exams but you will do
better in all of your classes and
remember you're graded on a curve so you
just have to get better than everybody
else most people don't have the
motivation to take practice exams that
they're daunting it seems like it's a
waste of time as opposed to learning
more substantive law but learning
substantive law hits a wall you hit
diminishing returns
most people don't spend any time
learning how to take law school exams
and the way that most classes are taught
is completely antiquated but you can
turn that to your advantage be one of
the people that gets the insights and
gets the feedback with practice exams
and courses like legal eagle and others
learning to do well in law school is a
skill and skills can be practiced and
they can be learned or in other words
it's like a muscle but as long as you
work out that muscle that muscle will
get stronger and if you don't work out
that muscle it will atrophy and law
school exams are exactly the same way
you can do better in law school it's
science if you liked this video please
click like and subscribe for more law
school crushing tips also please click
the link below to download our free
checklist that will
you crush your final exams thanks for
stopping by
[Music]